hello everyone and welcome to game
number 15 of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael Tao
and Mikhail Botvinnik now as you've seen
my previous 14 games in my previous 14
videos if you haven't there will be a
link in the description below where you
can check all of them out
Tala is currently in the lead by two
points it's sick it's 8 to 6 in towels
favor and Tom needs 12 and a half points
to actually win the match and become the
world champion but as you see there is a
nice goal by Alexandre de chien above
the board there are many chess players
who can play very well to win but
masters can draw it will and even though
you know allium was a great player at
all didn't agree with him all the way I
totally didn't actually think he can
actually draw all the games that as it's
eight eight to the six he would need
like five five drawn games in a row to
to actually become world champion so he
still felt both him and Coblentz that he
needed to create something so he did
deviate from efore in the past in the
previous couple of games but he decided
to return to e4 so in this game again
tile has the white pieces and he opens
with E for Botvinnik once again c6 we
have the kurakin defense once again as a
towel so far didn't didn't really manage
to get any advantage with white against
the CARICOM d4 d5 Knight to c3 D
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4
Bishop to f5 Knight to g3 so the
classical variation this has been played
in all of the games Bishop to g6 and in
all of the previous game style continued
with Knight to e2 with the idea of going
Knight to f4 and then pushing h4 h5 and
so on here all decided to go Bishop to
c4 Bishop to c4 which the idea that he
wants to leave this as an option he
doesn't want to commit with h4
immediately so a botany decided to play
east six and only now did he play Knight
to e2 and here he is basically inviting
both eunuch for a very short variation
which starts with Knight to f6 but both
eunuch doesn't want to go for this as he
didn't expect at all now to play e4 and
to go for this line so he plays Bishop
to d6 Bishop to d6 avoids complications
but now
black is forced to give up his dark
square bishop and this is no these are
small nuances but a dark dark square
bishop is a very important defending
piece in the caro-kann especially in
this variation so now top pushes h4 the
thread is of course h5 and we have h6
and now Knight to f4 and now Bishop must
capture night if you go Bishop to h7
then you get tonight the g2 h5 and then
there's the thread of Knight captures on
g7 black would have to defend with King
to f8 and this will be a pretty big a
pretty big deal for whites to achieve a
position like this
so after Knight to a4 Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now Knight to f6
here tau play the Queen to d2 Queen to
d2 was a move that was a bit more quiet
than tau would enjoy but the problem is
that the sharp h5 that leads to a pawn
sacrifice after Bishop to h7 and Queen
to e2 where he offers the d4 pawn what
ideas of going Bishop to e5 in the
castling in the future Queen side was
already played by Geller against his in
his game against beginner but tau was
tall was pretty sure that Botvinnik knew
of this game so instead he went for the
Queen Queen d2 move for the time
defending the d4 pawn Knight to d7 now
comes queenside castle and not nice to
d5 and here rook d2 e 1 tall doesn't
mind giving up his dark square bishop
for improving the position of his queen
we have 9th to b6 Bishop to b3 and now
Knight captures on f4 f5 was also an
option for black to kinda start his own
expansion on the Queen side but tal says
that here he would simply continue 8 3
and then a 4 Bishop to e2 and again
black black didn't really achieve
anything here if Knight if this night
would ever capture this Bishop then the
night on b6 could become a weak piece
so after Bishop to b3 Knight captures
Queen captures and now Knight to d5 here
of course a5 was no longer an option
because now White has Bishop captures
and e6 and black black will either
either admit that this was a silly idea
and
castle run away of course if he captures
the bishop then after rook captures
there's nowhere for the King to go King
b7 rogue this Exodus wins the Queen and
the game so after Queen to f4 and now as
I said a5 is no longer an idea Knight to
d5 attacking the Queen Queen to e5 an
excellent Square for the Queen
threatening that g7 pawn we have castles
and now Knight to e4 Knight to e4
what's the idea that Talos Botvinnik is
gonna play Queen to b8 try to exchange
Queens he wants to block this with
Knight to d6 another thing is if
botanique would capture this then this
would be an excellent exchange this
light square bishop is an excellent
defender and another thing is he did
decide that okay he did consider f4 f4
seemed like an idea
preparing to push f5 but after rook to
e8 there's really no point now in
pushing f5 and now this pawn structure
on the Kings side looks pretty weird
now f5 is simply met with Bishop
captures and ice captures pawn captures
now you can play Queen captures on f5
and after the exchange here black can
even play Queen captures on h4 is
threatened rook here you're up a pawn is
black and it's it's a better position
for black so after considering all of
this Knight to e4 Queen to b8 and about
any offers the trade of Queens and here
Knight to d6 tall doesn't mind trading
Queens as the title of the video
suggests but he wants to trade Queens on
his own terms if he trades Queens he
wants to play Knight to c4 and then
capture with the knight on e5 so he
wants this FF square for his Knight and
he says that if botanique tries to stop
this would be 5 not allowing Knight to
c4 then targets an excellent attack with
h5 kicking away the Bishop Bishop to age
7 and then rook to h3 and now it would
get very dangerous here as the rook is
coming to g3 the Queen and rook would be
pressuring g7 another excellent position
for tau
so after Knight to d6 rook to dat now
attacking attacking the knight here nice
to see forest bland
although instead of Knight to c4 h5 was
also an idea
and now if Queen captures you have the
option of playing pawn captures and
after pawn captures Queen captures here
with Czech Queen captures rook captures
and it would be a better position for
white but Thal thought that he could he
could even do better than this but there
is a very interesting line that after h5
Queen not Queen captures on d6 but it's
very interesting if black plays Bishop
to h7 then then white has this Knight
captures on f7 idea King captures Queen
captures any sex with check came to f8
and now rook to e3 a threatening the
terrible rook f3 check so only way to
prevent this is Queen to f4 to pin the
rook on e3 but now White has rook to h4
attacking the Queen Queen characters and
now rook to f3 Queen blocks rook
captures queen and pawn captures and now
see for pretty much all forced Bishop to
g8 attacking the Queen Queen f5 not the
knight has to move 97 Queen captures
with check King moves and now d5 and
it's I mean bug does have two rooks and
Knight and the bishop against the Queen
and the bishop but a white will capture
the h6 pawn so this H bond will be quite
dangerous and here after captures and
Bishop to a4 check black will have to
give up at least the exchange so after
captures captures and c5 it's a it's a
very delicate position where white
definitely has chances due to the past
h1 he will grab the h6 pawn and then he
will start pushing pawns on the King
side but as a Botanic of course would
not play Bishop to e7 there was no need
to even consider doing things like this
so Knight to c4 offering a trade and
first night the b6 but winning doesn't
want to trade Queens immediately if he
captures then towel doesn't have to
capture with the night he can even
capture with the pawn and strengthen his
grasp of the d6 square so instead of
this night to be six Queen capture some
b8 a rook a capture some b8 and now
Knight to e5 Bishop finally goes to h7
rock to h3 and now toss says that he
doesn't really need the Queen to start a
tagging here
he can sacrifice the d4 pawn if botany
captures it then comes Knight captures
on f7 King captures and now Bishop
captures on a on e6 with check King has
to move to e7 and now Bishop to f5 wins
back the piece King moves Bishop
captures top would be upper piece and
with with pawns on both sides of the
board he has a bishop against tonight he
was a very confident in in being able to
win this position so after rook to h3
botanique doesn't dare to touch the d4
pawn he plays nice taste
Knight to d7 and here c3 by tall
Knight to d7 is an excellent the
defensive move against the variation
Knight captures on f7 because now it
doesn't work because after King
characters and Bishop captures an e6
check and in the previous variation the
King could go to d7 maybe d8 but he'd
have to go to the D file here he can go
to the DF file or came to f8 and now
rook to f3 doesn't work as in the
previous variation where the King would
have to go back and now the knight can
simply block Knight to f6 white is down
a piece and black is winning so like I
said instead of this c3 simply defending
this pawn Knight captures on e5 rook
captures on e5 and now b6 we have rook
to e3 rook to see it we have Bishop to
c4 rook to c7 b4 now King to f8 g for
now tile starts pushing on the King side
as he did kind of immobilized the Queen
side Bishop to g8 but when it doesn't
really have a move here
the idea of g4 is also setting up a very
deadly trap for Botvinnik here tal was
hoping that both we could play f6 in in
hopes of raqqa captures and then Bishop
to g8 kind of winning toss that winning
the exchange as the rook can't move the
bishop on c4 is undefended but there is
a problem after this f6 move there is
rook to f3 by tau and now black is in a
whole lot of trouble
he can't capture and White has all the
time in the world to capture d6 pawn you
can't move the King if you go here or
here or here or here the Rope will
capture with check if you go here then
the bishop will capture if you play
anything else
if you don't move it then it's pinned if
you defend with the bishop or with the
rook you can always just capture the e6
pawn no troubles there
so after G for both me doesn't fall for
it
Bishop to g8 now comes and Bishop to b3
Bishop back to h7 again botany
doesn't really have a move f4 push it
back to g8 Bible tunic King 2b to Bishop
back to h7 again botanic really tries
that doesn't have a move and basically
he's just waiting for tile to make a
rash decision and Todd did start
improving the position of asking and
everything and here he plays h5 he says
h5 might have been the best move chess
wise but it might not have been the best
move you know in in any sporting sense
better yet you know it's better not to
make any decisions better maybe I had to
bring this Bishop over to the Kings side
where it will be useful for example on
g2 maybe expand further on on the Queen
side you know set everything right and
only then decide and any structure
changing move but okay he played h5 and
now we have rook d2 c8 Bishop de sitio
preparing his maneuver with the bishop
bishop back to g8 and here tau was very
pleased by bought an exhibition up to g8
move as both the bottom you can tell
were convinced that if there is an
exchange of bishops that the rooks Rock
endgame would be winning for tau so G 5
f6 now rook to e4 c5 and finally both
eunuch was able to push c5 Bishop to b3
attacking the six pawn and now C capture
some before this Bishop to b3 Intel's
opinion is the move that could have
could have been made better probably
here captures captures and a3 was was
much needed to continue this game with
an h4 wooden h4 white
but after c5 Bishop to b3 here we had
seek after some before we have C capture
some before and now H capture some g5f
capture some g5
capture some g5 and rock the g3 going
for the g5 pawn rook to f7 rock captures
on g5 now rook to have to check and King
to h3 this is more for t1 and this is
where the game was adjourned Tom made
his King to a to remove and the
botanique had botnik also made a move
but it will it will only be discovered
tomorrow what he had played so tau spent
the entire night with complaints
analyzing disposition both unique of
course analyzed the position as well tau
and what Tull and coolants thought that
botanic would have played Bishop to f7
but as Botnick showed the other day and
they reached to a draw botnik simply
showed the variation that he analyzed
the entire night it was a rock c7 with
the move botnik plate and after rook
Ruby g4 doubling on the G file now
threatening to exchange rooks as H 6 was
was a threat rook captures pawn captures
rook to f4 now Bishop captures on b3 you
can't capture first like an in-between
move because simply Bishop blocks so a
king captures and now rook to f7
defending the pawn king moves king moves
improving the position both players king
c6 came to g5 attacking the rook and
after King moves at for both tau and
botanique would have nice pass pawns but
in India and it would definitely be at a
drone a drone game so game 15 also ends
in a draw now the result is 8 and a half
to 6 and a half in toss favor so 12 and
a half points is needed we are almost
almost at the end of this great series
so a couple of more games to go so do
you know do stay tuned I will probably
finish this series before starting
anything else and after I finish this I
mean we did have the candidates and the
Greinke chess classic so a lot of modern
tournaments I will be checking your
suggestions that you've left in the
comment says I haven't visited them for
quite a while that is I've been fairly
busy with the current events
so yeah that's game 15 I do hope you
enjoyed it
I would like to thank Brandon booth
so the dank hudak mattel dog Nala and
loft or immundus on for a conversion to
my channel thank a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I will make
both of them videos from this series
once again in the description below
there is a link where you can check out
all of the games from this match and if
you haven't feel free to check out also
my series about the 1959 candidates
tournament the tournament all had to win
to actually get this opportunity to
challenge botany for the title so yeah
Oh once again check check the video
search the hell links in the description
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon